Games usually have
a lot of image assets.
Not always.
Some games create quite a bit
of their imagery programatically
actually using simple
graphics primitives.
But it's definitely more
common to represent actors and
objects with sprite images or 3D models,
depending on the type of game.
When you add textures, backgrounds,
icons, badges, buttons, and
other UI elements.
The list of image resources you have to
keep track of just keeps getting longer
and longer, especially when you may
need multiple copies of an image
with a different level of detail for
each.
In these cases, it becomes more
efficient to combine related images into
a single sprite sheet or texture atlas.
There's a little more overhead in the
drawing code but loading becomes much
faster, much simpler and
typically you even save storage space
because the combined images compress
better than they do individually.